the european commission has taken legal
action against pharmaceutical company
astrazeneca
it says the vaccine manufacturer has
breached its contract to supply enough
of the covert 19
jab the eu's executive branch says the
company also has not come up with a
strategy to ensure
the timely delivery of doses natasha
butler is live in paris
natasha why is the commission taking
this legal action against astrazeneca
well the commission is probably looking
to put more pressure on astrazeneca and
certainly salvage some of its
uh reputation because the commission has
come
under a lot of criticism from some
member states over the past few months
over the slow
uh vaccine rollout in the european union
commission blaming in part this slow
rollout
on astrazeneca either way it is
certainly
just the latest twist in this ongoing
round between
the british swedish pharmaceutical
company and
the eu commission now the commission
says that it is launching this legal
action
because astrazeneca in its opinion has
breached its contract has failed to
deliver
the number of doses it was supposed uh
to deliver
as agreed now uh astrazeneca delivered
30 million doses
in the first quarter of the year to the
eu
that is far from the 120 million doses
that the eu commission
says that it had actually promised to
deliver the eu commission
also said that astrazeneca could have
for example diverted some doses that
were produced in the uk
to the eu to try and make up the
shortfall
now we have heard from astrazeneca they
have given a response
uh to this legal action being launched
against them they say that
they say that it has no merit and that
they look
forward to the opportunity to be able to
clear their name
now natasha all the eu states had backed
this plan
although some raised concerns about uh
legal action tell us more
well the eu commission met with
diplomats from the eu member states last
week
to try and garner support for uh this
plan now we know as you say the eu
member states have all
uh backed the plan nevertheless there
was some concern among some of the
member states
we know france for example amongst them
and germany
were worried that this legal action
comes at a time when obviously the eu is
still battling the pandemic many
countries including here in france for
example still
in a third wave astrazeneca vaccine is
one of the tools being used
to try and stop uh the further spread of
the virus so
uh in a way launching legal action
against the company that's due to supply
another 70 million doses in the next
quarter
could be seen as counterproductive also
there's a real risk
of further damaging the reputation of
astrazeneca
a vaccine that has already uh had its
reputation
sorely shaken over the past few weeks
and months by
several governments in the eu because
the conflicting advice
information uh on the astrazeneca
vaccine now eu governments have really
been at pains over the last
weeks to say this vaccine is safe uh its
benefits outweigh the risks nevertheless
all of that criticism has shaken the
reputation of this vaccine
in the eu at a time when it is needed as
i said
as part of this vaccine rollout okay
natasha butler they're live
in paris thank you natasha